miles de senegaleses marcharon en la
capital dakar contra la homosexualidad
después de que el parlamento rechazara
un texto que pretendía endurecer aún más
las leyes en curas la comunidad lgtb el
mensaje está claro
pedimos que la asamblea nacional
criminalice la homosexualidad en senegal
simplemente si no lo hacen echaremos a
los diputados del poder y traeremos
otros que estén dispuestos a votar esta
ley
sin embargo el código penal ya son zonas
severamente las relaciones sexuales
entre personas del mismo sexo imponen
los sanciones de entre 1 y 5 años de
cárcel la legislación criticada por las
organizaciones de derechos humanos pero
insuficiente para los manifestantes la
llamada la movilización fue hecha por
125 asociaciones reunidas adentro de un
mismo colectivo la oposición a los
derechos l gmt se ha convertido en una
fuerza de movilización política de los
tradicionalistas que denuncian una
influencia occidental en el país
no puedo acabar sin decir las naciones
unidas- que su agenda está condenada al
fracaso en senegal
nunca la inclusión de la comunidad el
grt tendrá lugar en nuestro querido país
de la hospitalidad
de los 45 países de áfrica sub-sahariana
28 tienen una legislación que reprime la
homosexualidad